Hello and welcome to this video on customizing your nav volumes.
So we have set up our navmate volume here and we possibly have even added in
secondary agents so that we've got different nav meshes for different sizes.
Now I'm going to go over and I'm going to show you how we can edit our
our volumes to change it to make it sort of fit our gameplay.
So the first thing that I'm going to drag in is something that's called a nav mesh modifier.
So if I jump into here type in nav you'll see that we have the nav mesh modifier volume.
This is another volume that's going to allow us to change an area.
So as you can see the first thing that happens as I drag one in and as I pull it out it cancels
out the nav mesh. So it works as a negative for the nav mesh as it is.
So if you don't want your AI to be going to a specific location, unable to go there,
you can manually place these in to update what we've got.
So again if we were to see this running we'd actually see that the player starts right in
the middle of it. So I drag the player start out and push play and go show navigation.
So you're going to see that our character just cannot walk through this area.
Yeah, that's pretty straightforward.
Now I'm going to be typing in show navigation a lot.
So what I'm going to do is I'm just going to jump into our open level blueprint.
And we don't need that.
And I am going to execute the console command and I'll type in show navigation here.
So this is just a quick way so that it executes the command on play.
And you can see that when we start we can actually see our navigation at that point.
OK, so we have other options when it comes to our nav mesh modifier.
So if we select the modifier that we have, and let's have a look at the details panel,
you can see that the area class that we have, the area nav area is underscore null.
Now, if you do a drop down, you can see that we have a few different options.
We have obstacle, low height and null.
So low height, this works with the crouch ability.
It means they're going to have to crouch in order to pass by.
And the one I want to go into is obstacle.
Now, with the obstacle, you're going to see that the area is turned to...
It's suddenly changed to a different colour.
So it's changed to a sort of orange colour.
Now, if I drag, if I reduce that down in width, so I'm looking for...
I change that to 0.4.
Right, now we can see that when we're playing, the character is going to avoid this.
Again, it works like a null one, but we're capable of, if we were to...
I'm going to grab my major, my main one.
I'm going to reduce that down in size.
So that.
Now, if you start, even though it's an obstacle, they are going to pass through it.
But they're only going to pass through it if they have no other option to pass through it.
So this is great.
Say, for example, you have a pond or something like that,
where normally a character would never walk through the pond.
But if it was the only way to get to the central island and you told them to get there,
then it would pass through that area.
However, what if you want to create an area which doesn't completely block them,
but something like, I don't know, grass.
If you had an urban scene and you want people to walk on the streets,
but you didn't want them to walk on the grass.
Or say you had an area that had tar in it that slowed people down or something like that.
And you wanted that to be taken into consideration with the NavMesh.
Now, what you could do then is we've got our NavMesh modifier here,
and we got the selections of these ones.
You can actually go away and create your own.
So if I was to right-hand click and select the Blueprint class
and search for NavArea class, I think.
Yes.
OK, so here we go. NavArea.
Right.
So if we start with the NavArea as the top one,
we've got these numbers and ones below it.
If I was to select the NavArea,
and I call this NavArea, NavArea underscore grass.
So if I double click on that, you'll see that we have our own setup here.
Now we don't actually have any override functionality in this at all.
So you don't really want to be coding anything in this.
What we care about is the class defaults here.
So you can see we've got a couple of settings at the default cost.
So at the moment, this is one, and we've got the fixed area entering costs.
So what you could either do is you could create a one for a path,
which has a lower cost, so that would encourage people to use that path.
Or you could create one that is higher.
In this case, that's what we're going to do.
We're going to create one default cost of two.
And it has a fixed area entering cost as well.
So we could have it that there is a 0.5 cost to just entering the area.
So this means that now walking through that is going to cost twice as much.
So if I jump back in and I grab our NavModifier volume,
you'll see in the drop down box, I now have grass.
OK, and that's in pink.
Now let's try this now.
So I've got my character.
If I move down to the bottom and I click on the other side,
he's going to walk across because he does the maths,
and it's going to be cheaper to walk across here
than it will be to go all the way around from the other side.
OK, however, if he comes over to the side here,
and let's get closer, he's going to walk around
because it's actually going to calculate to be cheaper for him.
He's going to respect and he's not going to tread on the grass.
So you can see we can just create a modifier
which will slightly adapt the changes and how the character moves.
So let's have a quick look at the NamMeshBounds volume.
Let's have a look at the recast and you'll see if I click on the costs,
draw polygon costs, you can see that we have a fixed cost of 2 plus 0.5 for entering.
So everything around the outside is at 1.
However, this is a slightly higher cost because we've created this NavMeshModifier.
So that's a useful tool where you can update how the paths are calculated
based on specific areas.
And this is quite nice as well to make navigation look more natural,
but also to split up mobs as they're moving around.
They can choose different paths accordingly.
OK, so that are your options.
Your NavMeshModifier can block an area.
We could create one that makes it cheaper.
We could create one that tells them it is a low height
and wouldn't be able to come through.
And you can create an obstacle which it will only cross if it has to.
OK, thanks a lot.
We'll see you in the next video where we will be looking at
how we can connect up disconnected areas within the map.